contact hallo mein name ist zypern ich
teste heute fällt gegen originale
süßigkeiten wir waren in verschiedenen
supermärkten unterwegs und haben uns von
so marten die beispielsweise uri oder
prinzenrolle oder brauchen die oder
einzelner haribo einerseits die
originalprodukte gekauft und auf der
anderen seite dann von anderen
herstellern die nachgemachten produkte
jule befindet sich von hinter der kamera
und gibt mir immer einen snack oder ein
originales produkt und ich werde beide
probieren und werde sagen was fehlt und
was original ist also wir fangen an
als erstes nehmen wir die uhr also ich
probiere jetzt erstmal den rechten
choreo ganz ganz ein
glaub ich kann jetzt schon sagen die
sonne sich in letzter zeit etwas sehr
sehr viel holte gestern bei der flecken
ohne den zweiten probiert zu haben sage
ich dass das hier fertig und das
original so eindruck dass sich ist
übrigens kein placement für irgendeinen
süßwarenhersteller den wir hier jetzt
probieren werden sondern alles ja selbst
gekauft jetzt nehmen wir den tricks wind
vix muss mir geben den tricks werd ich
mir das natürlich nicht komplett in
wunschteam aber ich probiere auch erst
mal wieder die rechte seite weltkriegs
halt nicht so heute deswegen punkte habe
ich überhaupt kein plan gerade probiert
mal links
das mit schweinen original gegeben
ich habe absolut keine ahnung schmeckt
haargenau weiß ich würde einfach mal
sagen dass rechts original ist und links
vechta das komplette rad und hatte sogar
kunstvollen noch gedacht dass ich sage
dass links original ist weil er sich so
ein bisschen hochwertiger enthüllt die
sehen doch haargenau gleich ausland das
ist so krage guck mal die sehen genau
gleich aus dass sie jetzt original und
das ihres täters
das ist krank man erkennt einfach gar
keinen unterschied jährige jetzt nehmen
wir die adams dieser moment kriege ich
mehrere von allen guten geistern
wer wird sie also die m&s bzw wie heißt
noch mal die fakes dinge also sie fühlen
sich exakt gleich alles probiere mal
wieder zuerst den rechten arm und
schmeckt original aber es hat die bisher
bei jedem produkt
würde ich sagen eigentlich das original
probier doch mal den linken genau gleich
genau wie schaffen es diese ganzen
nachgemachten süßwaren hersteller genau
das genau gleich das ist genau wirklich
exakt bleibt schmeckt ich weiß gar nicht
mehr was rechts und was links war
ich würde aber trotzdem sagen dass
rechts original war und links fällt zum
wieder rechte also keiner kann mich hier
verstärkt
nicola alter fällt auch save safe
straffen cola gegen pepsi
ich probiere erst mal wieder das recht
gegen rechts ist patientin cisco dann
wieder etwas getrunken
dann nehmen wir das ja ich liebe kokos
ich weiß gar nicht wo die kamera ist
aber wenn ihr das jetzt auch seht ich
glaube das liegt auch genau wieder
gleich aus weil es fühlt sich auf jeden
fall genau gleich anprobiert zuerst mal
wieder die rechte seite schmeckt einfach
nur ekelhaft finde ich gut aufgehoben
also das rechtlich habe ich jetzt schon
probiert und es hat einfach noch
apathisch geschmeckt deswegen ich weiß
nicht ob das echte bauern die wirklich
auch sehr gelacht schmeckt deswegen will
ich sagen recht sperrig links original
wenn ich alte okay wenn das echte schon
echt nicht gut schmeckt was heißt nicht
gut ist es ja immer geschmackssache aber
ich hasse halt einfach kurz die tür
wieder exakt gleich aus freunde das ist
echt krank jetzt nehmen wir wieder ein
keks die prinzenrolle die prinzen dann
kommt so heißt noch nicht dass video
[Musik]
nein das ist das so
der schmeckt original alles klar ich
sage jetzt dass ich die nächsten alle
richtig haben werde jetzt nehmen wir das
fruchtiges gummibärchen okay also allein
so vom fühlen kann ich auf jeden fall
sagen dass sie sich wirklich exakt
gleich anfühlen ich probiere mal wieder
erst mal das recht
[Musik]
welche farbe rot grün hätte diese
menschen früher mal gesagt habe ich
wieder mal unbedingt die roten
gummibärchen nicht mehr am besten das
schmeckt genau gleich alles nicht mehr
schmeckt doch bedeutet jahre das ist oft
noch bewegen erklärt flinke erste
originale das ist wichtig danke an der
stelle kann ich nur sagen das ist das
letzte das ist pickup sorry aber da
fühlt man von banfield davon dass das
recht ist auf jeden fall viel klasse mit
den einkerbungen und sohnemann im linken
fühlt man richtig diesem text außenrum
recht schmeckt doch einfach komplett
anders also praktisch das fading und
links das original sagt er das hatte nur
zwei sachen falsch oder eigentlich sind
wir jetzt schon durch mit den produkten
die wir eingekauft hatten also wir haben
irgendwie keine ahnung wie viele pakete
das wahrnehmen die so 15 stück oder so
verschiedene sachen 15 kommt er gar
nicht hin weil das wären sieben gebracht
werden auf jeden fall echt viele sachen
eingekauft und was wir uns gerade
gedacht haben was er kann man eigentlich
leitungswasser von so wolkig wasserball
schrittweise unterscheiden das sind die
beiden getränke probiere wie immer das
rechte getränke jetzt links offen
das ist häufig yamaha das schon ein
bisschen andere das war mir familie
meine damen und herren meine augen tun
weh weil ich dieses komische lampen ding
hier so toll gemacht habe ich habe ein
paar monaten bzw jahren diese ganzen
real würde spey die süßigkeiten die
videos gesehen und dachte mir so hätte
es eigentlich über schwere kriegen die
das alle hin und ich dachte wirklich
dass sich als jemand der jetzt wirklich
nicht allzu häufig schokolade ist und
sogar wirklich total verpacken werden
aber man schmeckt schon noch starke
unterschiede also die produkte sehen
teilweise genau gleich aus wie weit
also beim tricks lag ich ja
beispielsweise auch falsche bei der
prinzenrolle auf aber es ist auf jeden
fall extras wie gewissen
lebensmittel-hersteller andere
lebensmittel hersteller einfach so genau
kopieren können dass man echt keinen
unterschied mehr auf jeden fall rat ist
jetzt vom video weiter namen hören wenn
es euch gefallen haben das gerne mal
einen leiter schaffen die rund 40.000
like-buttons wäre ganz schön und das
wird man schon viel das auto ob das was
ihr vom video das war's jetzt ihr vom
video hier können jetzt hier mal den
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auch die glocken
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]